[Music]
hallo YouTube chest lowers my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
28th episode of dirty chest tricks in
this episode I'm going to show you some
of the wonderful tricks against Sicilian
hyper excited dragon which arises after
the water
efore c5 Knight to f3 and now black
plays the moon g6 here my recommendation
is you continue with the moon d4 and now
black has two popular choice in this
position in this video we are going to
concentrate on the move Bishop to g7
however if you open in place C captures
d4
then I am recommending that you should
capture with the Queen and I have
included a sample game in the PGN we're
super Grandmaster vessel inter Paulo has
been crushed by his low ranked opponent
and the setup used by the white is very
easy to learn yet very effective okay
Bishop to g7 black's idea is to create
the pressure in the center as quickly as
possible however white has this tricky
move in the picture that is d capture c5
the mainline continue with the Queen
check and after the move c3 black regain
his pawn with the move Queen capture c5
here white has tried many options but
I'm going to show you a very tricky move
which not only contain a lot of tricks
but as we will see against the most
popular responses by the black-white get
a tremendous advantage and attacking
position the tricky move is Knight to b3
as I have highlighted over here black
has try this three good options and
against each of them
white has some great shock weapons
the first more I want to consider is d6
well after that
why should continue with the following
plan first of all Bishop to b3 attacking
the Queen kindly note Queen cannot go to
the c7 the simple reason is after Knight
to be Phi and Queen to c6 white can get
upon just early in the hog name so
that's why after Bishop to e3 that
should play the accurate move Queen to
e5
well after that white attack will
continue with the move Knight to c4
hitting the Queen and after the move
Queen to c7 White has this tricky move
in the picture
Knight to d4 so clearly white has a
threat of Knight to B Phi and black
cannot ignore it for example in one
online blitz game my opponent continued
here with the move Knight to f6 but
after the moonlight to be fine it was
very clear that white emerged with an
extra pawn utterly in the opening and
black cannot even touch that pawn the
simple reason is after Knight to b6
there's a great disaster and the black
cam so this is what happened if black
ignored the threat of a knight to be
filed
now there are two lays black can't
defend this threat one is Bishop to d7
and the second one is a six if you open
in place Bishop to d7 then once again I
have included a model game where white
player has crushed the black within 28
moves so the move which I'm going to
focus on in this video is a 6 well
obviously it's stopping knight to be
fire but it leads to the another
disastrous position for the black and
white has this amazing shot in this
position Knight to a5 hahaha well that
bishop is attack and black has to do
something about this now if you open in
place Bishop back to f8 then the
simplest is you take the spawn but
check and after pawn takes and night to
be six white regain the exchange just
within 12 moves the simple reason is
tonight to defy white indeed get decks
change okay but what happens if you open
an accept this piece sacrifice well more
or less same story because after G
captures fi white will continue with the
moonlight to be six and this time around
black and take an extra pawn after F
captures efore but then after Knight
captures aid Queen to c6 White has this
wonderful move Queen to defy which not
only simplify the position as white
regain the piece with a folk and after
King to d8 and Knight captures defy
within 15 moves white obtain a rook for
the night and a pawn which is always a
decisive advantage
the second more I want to consider is
Knight to f6 which is in fact the
highest played move as per the whole
line database but once again why it has
a very simple but effective set up you
start with the move Bishop to e3
attacking the Queen Queen to a5 and now
the familiar territory yup Knight to c4
crane to c7 and night to d4 the slammer
on black has few good choices kindly
note a 6 once again leads to the
disaster after the Moon Knight - Fi so
that's not a choice for the black let's
see what happens if you open in place
other moves the first more I want to
consider is castle on the Kings side
well after that if your opponent allow
then you are always going to put this
knight on the B 5 and now black has to
play some careful moves for example if
you open place Queen to d8 then the
simplest is you play e5
hitting the 9 and after Knight goes
somewhere let's say night to e aid you
can in fact win this pawn in a broad
daylight and it's very funny that black
pcs are doing photo shoot at the back
rank so the more accurate response over
here is Queen to c6 however but can
still take this a7 pawn and this time
around situation is even worst because
if black foolishly take this pawn then
after nightcap to c8 rook kept to see it
and night to be six white obtained a
varying position the 3rd mu I want to
consider over here is Knight to c6
well no prize for guessing west next
reply which is very obvious Knight to be
5 and now black has to play the careful
move Queen to be 8 the simple reason why
Queen to d8 is a very bad move as white
attack roll down on the bowl with the
move e5 and after the move Knight to g8
we have the same pawn grabbing story
Knight captures a 7 this time around
this move is more poisonous because
if black foolishly take the snide then
there comes Bishop to b6 trapping the
black queen so it is very obvious that
at this point black has to play the move
Queen to b8 after that I'm going to
propose a move which will completely
demolish black petition before I show
you I want you to pause this video and
find out what is the best reply and
disposition okay I hope you find this
wonderful Blue Knight to d6 check hahaha
and black position is completely
crumbling for example if King to f8 then
black position is already verse and here
White has this forcing sequence that is
Aoife hitting the knight Knight to e8
and after Knight captures King captures
and the MU f4 not only black and not
Castle but blacks opening is turn out
bit of joke so that's why at this
position black has to accept this piece
sacrifice he catches d6 and now can you
see the big point behind this piece
sacrifice I hope you do and find this
wonderful move Bishop to f4 so what idea
is to trap the black Queen and amazingly
enough black doesn't have much good
squares for the screen I got this
position two times in the online games
where in the first game
my opponent try the moon b6 which I
think already a big time mistake because
after Knight check King to a fade and
now Bishop to g3 white is all set to
create havoc in the black camp my
opponent try the Moon Knight to h5
hitting the Bashar
but then comes Queen to b3 threatening
of mate he defended with the move Knight
to d8 I took the f7 pawn hitting the
Queen my opponent captured the bishop I
capture his Knight so once
threatening a mate he played defy
but then the following sequence gives
wide a winning age after Queen check
King to e8 Knight to c6 attacking the
Queen Queen to c7 and now I simply took
this Knight and my opponent realized
that he has a horrible position because
he cannot take my knight and not only
white emerge with an two extra pawn but
black King cannot castle probably the
most critical response at this position
is what happens if your parent plays
Knight captures efore well here white
has to play some accurate moves and the
sequence start with the move Knight
captures d6 check in the game my
opponent tried King to f8 but I have
also attached King to e7 in the PG in so
you can check it out after King to f8 I
responded with the move Queen to defy
hitting two spots my opponent obviously
defended the maid but then comes Queen
captures efore threatening her checkmate
he defended with the move Knight to e6
I played Bishop to g3 and now indeed
similar threats are on the ball he tried
Queen to c7 I played Queen to f3 and
after the Moon Knight to g5 I created
the same threat once again with the move
Queen to b3 at this position probably
Queen to d8 is a better try but because
my appearance Knight was hanging he
thought that this is a force draw after
Knight to e6 but what he missed is White
has this amazing shot in the picture
that is night 2fi hitting the Queen and
after the move Queen to d8 by force
white can win blacks Queen before I move
on I like you to calculate how white can
get blacks Queen okay I hope you find
this wonderful continuation that is
Bishop
d6 check King to g8 Knight to e7 check
King to afaid and now Knight to c6 we
lap the black queen
the third and the final move by the
black is what happens if your Oakland
plays Bishop capture c3 I think this is
one of the most critical reply and what
should know exactly what he's going to
do about it because after be capture c3
in queen capture c3 black is threatening
the whole rook and that's why this line
looks so attractive but in fact white
has invited black to his dirty cam and
the trick
start with the move Queen to d2 offering
the whole rook
well of course black is going to take it
and it doesn't look like white has any
sort of compensation
well perception can be deceptive and
here white reveal his nasty plan with
the move Knight to be file so white is
clearly threatening the move Knight to
c7 the most accurate response over here
is Knight to e6 but first of all we
should see what happens if you open
place Knight to f6 threatening efore
we're here White has a very simple idea
that is Bishop to d3 protecting the e4
pawn and now white is all set to trap
that Queen for example a simple line can
run like this like - a6 castle on the
Kings side castle on the Kings side and
now the simple ePHI hitting the knight
Knight to d5 and Bishop to e3 trapping
the Queen once and for all
so black has to forcefully take this
rook after Bishop captures f1 not only
white emerge with an extra piece but if
black is not careful enough then things
can go from back to worse I reach this
position in a blitz game where my
opponent try the move Knight to c7 and I
show him the power of this position with
the move Queen 26 so not only white is
threatening the move Bishop captures c7
and Bishop to f6 but Knight to g5 is
also in the air and it is very hard to
see how black is defend with the threat
for example in the game
he played rook to e8 but after Knight to
g5 he simply resign as White is
threatening a checkmate in two moves
okay let's consider the most critical
response that is Knight to b6 after that
I'm proposing white should continue with
the move Knight to c3
so not only safeguarding the b1 and a2
square but threatening the move Bishop
captures a6
if you operand allow this capture for
example if he plays the move Knight to
f6 then white can take this 9 and after
pawn captures the easier sequences you
castle on the King side after black
plays any move let's say d6 then Bishop
to b2 and after Queen takes and King
takes for a piece black has some
shattered pawns so it is very obvious
that at this position black cannot allow
this capture so the force reply is
Knight to c5 afterwards as for the chess
engine the base move suggested is Bishop
to c4 but I think it's bit risky the
more solid and a good approach is you
continue with the Moon Knight to d4
which is more simplified and has a very
clear plan kindly note in this position
if your opponent plays moves such as
Knight to f6 d6 or b6 any moves then you
can defend this pawn with the MOE f3 and
then on the next move you can play the
Moon Knight to c2 and nabbing the Queen
so the only critical response from the
black is he has to take this pawn and
after Knight captures efore blacks idea
is to escape his queen with the move
Queen to b1 so black is sacrificing some
material to get his Queen out of the
jail but still white obtain a decent
advantage why should continue with the
MU f3 and after the move Queen to b6 my
recommendation is you should continue
with the move Queen to c3 so there is a
discover attacked looming on the rook
so black response is force black has to
play Knight to f6 and now you continue
with the night
be file threatening on see seven black
and castle on the kingside but then
comes the whole point of the sequence
that is Knight to c7 attacking the rook
rook to b8 and now the star move Bishop
to b2 this move completely tied down f6
Knight and on top of everything what is
the threat of Knight to d5 I did this
position against traditional master
where my opponent try the move Queen to
c6 attacking both this Forge I responded
with the move Queen to e5 so white
thread remain as it is and it is just a
matter of time before white is
delivering the final blow after long
think my opponent come up with the move
b5 but I am afraid this is not stopping
the Moon Knight to defy and no matter
however black plays he get a completely
lost position
he played rook to b6 but after Knight to
e7 is simply resigned and you can see
the potential of this line if a title
player can finish in 20 moves what
happens to your opponent well I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful tricks in
the Bishop to g7 line of hyper exited
dragon feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care
but that f3 Knight is badly pin and on
top of everything White has this deadly
rook check so the big question arise how
white get a winning edge from this
position white reveal his amazing
attacking idea g4 hahaha well believe it
or not the only move to keep black in
the game that is Bishop to b6